[Musique]
david bennett 57 ans atteint d'une
maladie cardiaque en phase terminale à
côté de lui le docteur qui lui sauvera
la vie grâce à une opération
expérimentale une transplantation d'un
coeur de port pour remplacer le sien car
c'est bien le risque de rejet qui
rendait cette opération périlleuse pour
le limiter le port d'honneur a été
génétiquement modifiés de telle manière
qu'ils ne produisent pas le sucre
présent dans l'ensemble des cellules
porcine et qui provoque le rejet chez
l'homme il ya deux ans jour pour jour la
chine a annoncé le premier mort d'une
pneumonie atypique mort cause en réalité
donc par ce virus qui a modifié notre
quotidien à tous depuis deux ans et
soudain deux paumes de main tendue à
emmanuel macron sur ses mains dit lettre
écrite au feutre noir je t'emmerde
réaction du chef de l'état
les intimidations
les violences contre les élus de toutes
tendances se multiplient et s'aggrave je
tiens à dire solennellement que
l'assemblée nationale sera toujours aux
côtés de ses membres menacée vous êtes
aux cards une drôle de polémique
monsieur roussel pour avoir dit non mais
un moyen de défendre le bon vin la
gastronomie française c'est de permettre
aux français d'avoir accès ça a provoqué
une vague de critiques dans votre camp
le camp de la gauche une partie de la
gauche vous à transformer en chauvin
franchouillarde c'est gauche elle a
changé elle est voulue et je considère
que le mot socialisme est un mot mort
dépassé je pense que la chienne bonne
partie de la gauche qui veut plus de
vous est ce que ça vous blesse non mais
j'avais vu dans quel état elle l est je
suis moi-même à l'amateur de paella ma
grand-mère est espagnole j'adore le
tiramisu mon frère vit à rome a su
réaliser
des piétons attrapée par le bras obligé
de courir avant d'être brutalement lâché
par le conducteur
ces images provoque l'indignation et
qu'on parle du drapeau français de la
gastronomie française comme si on
employait des gros mots j'en suis fier
moi et je souhaite défendre cette
gastronomie française ces dernières
années notre pays emprunter sur les
marchés à des taux très intéressants
parfois même négatif mais aujourd'hui
l'économie va mieux et les taux
remontent 0 27% en janvier et même 0 75
% attendu à la fin de l'année loin
d'être une bonne nouvelle pour les
finances publiques c'est une première
dans son histoire ni stars derniers
fabricants de zinc en france sera sans
doute à l'arrêt à partir de dimanche en
cause la flambée des prix de
l'électricité
9,7 milliards d'euros c'est le déficit
commercial français en novembre c'est du
jamais vu un déficit historique qui nous
conduira sur l'année sans doute à une
accumulation de 87 milliards d'euros ces
derniers temps les prix se sont envolés
à des niveaux que j'aie jamais connue
dans ma carrière qui sont de plusieurs
centaines d'euros par mégawatt heure des
300 400 500 est à ce prix là l'économie
de la fabrication du zinc n'est pas
possible il est préférable de s'arrêter
chaussée à circulations douces et
regardez regardez si là on comprend et
hop
alors là que faire et bien là mais
qu'est ce qu'on fait on roule sur la
foulée dans la voie du milieu dans la
seule voix d'ailleurs la vidéo est une
voiture qui arrive enfin et c'est ça le
problème dans l'agriculture la situation
est encore plus catastrophique
la part de l'industrie française dans
l'industrie de la zone euro a chuté à
14,1 pour cent aujourd'hui c'est du
jamais vu le principe est que les
cyclistes circulent d'un côté de part et
d'autre de la chaussée et que les
voitures se croisent y compris à
contresens sur la voie unique du milieu
lee et jim young et candidat du parti
démocrate favori des sondages est bien à
une proposition qui fait le buzz sa
dernière idée est au coeur de la
campagne comme nous le raconte courrier
international il propose la prise en
charge par la sécurité sociale des soins
contre la calvitie autrement dit des
implants gratuits pour tous les coréens